welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of obi-wan
kenobi episode 6 the finale which
reveals that that second set of
footprints in the sand really belonged
to your old teacher who saw everything
you've been doing alone in your cave
let's break down this episode shot by
shot for all the star wars easter eggs
and details you missed quick
announcement you can see new rock stars
live in austin texas on saturday july
2nd as part of rtx rooster teeth's
podcast festival for discounted tickets
click the link in the description and
use the code new rockstars all one word
it's gonna be a lot of fun i hope to see
you there we've been on tatooine passing
some locals including some jawas a guy
carrying a sack of what looks like thin
melloroon fruits way too clean astromech
droid and then a line for water at a
portable evaporator cart boba fett
reminded us how water is a price
inflated commodity on this planet and
the vendor of it would of course know
omen lars as a moisture farmer owen
would be his supplier but the guy who
cuts in line is groff ditcher the
foreman from obi-wan's meat slice and
gig in episode 1 riva uses the force to
swat the cup out of his hand spilling
water a shocking wasteful display but
also showing how uninterested riva is in
her own current health she is on a
suicide mission whereas before riva and
the other inquisitors announced their
presence here riva is hooded a bandage
wrapped around her wounded midsection
and with her hair fluttering in her eyes
she's looking rough rokin's freighter
does some zigzag maneuvering to evade
darth vader's star destroyer the
devastator the imagery here paralleling
the opening chase of the tantive iv in a
new hope by the way it was not yet named
the tantive 4 in the 1977 film it was
later named that you can follow pablo
dogo's amazing twitter where he goes
into the history of all of that but yes
the imagery is awesome it starts with
the diamond-shaped hull slicing up
through the screen until our perspective
glides through the overhanging bridge
tower just dizzying us with the sense of
scale of this floating fortress pursuing
this by comparison tiny tiny fugitive
ship rokin reassures the refugees we'll
head for testing
get you out from there
yeah tessen is not an established planet
in star wars one of the few times ever
they mention the planet and it's not
already in lore underscoring this is
even more of a false promise from broken
like obi-wan's face reads like yeah
there's no testing in star wars why are
you lying leia uses lola to comfort
corin and his mother remember corrin
possibly being a nod decor and horn
legends character and son to jedi dalon
halcyon whose name appeared on the
auravesh on jabim and mapuzo luke and
owen proves a part shop where owen is
warned by his water vendor they head
home and peru reveals herself to be more
of a survivalist than we ever imagined
we both knew this day might come
she'll come when the suns go down
best we got position now so in the years
since anakin's visit attack of the
clones and obi-wan returning with a baby
and revenge of the sith brew thought
yeah shotgun behind the flower pod that
sounds good we don't need to tell owen
about this i bet she also hides thermal
detonators in the blue milk
obi-wan gives leia tala's blaster
holster with the notches for every jedi
she saved leia runs her finger over
these last of which tala would have
carved in for leia obi-wan inspects his
lightsaber and says this little prayer i
have to face him master
[Music]
whether he dies or i do
this ends today
yes no response for qui-gon but we
learned the end of the episode qui-gon
was there obi-wan cannot yet sense him
because he still needs some closure with
anakin obi-wan tells rokin there are not
many leaders left
people follow you
don't stop
just get started setting up broken it
sounds like to help future other jedi
runaways in a possible second season or
maybe on shows like andor or ahsoka
because ahsoka looks like it's gonna
flash back to the rebels era obi-wan
departs the freighter in this drop ship
that's him
my lord we must continue our pursuit of
the insurgents now is our chance to
wipe out this network in its entirety we
cannot prioritize one lone
jedi follow kenobi
at once more vader yes the grand
inquisitor bites his tongue but the
charles soul 2017 comics give us some
deeper context of the rivalry between
these two characters vader hates the
inquisitors almost as much as he hates
the jedi hatred is really the fuel that
keeps this whole operation running owen
warns luke the tuscans are on the hunt
again they're raiding farms along the
waist oh come on didn't we just learn
from boba fett that tuscans are not the
barbaric raiders that people think they
are i mean i'm not surprised at owen's
prejudice i'm just saying those moisture
farmers were on stolen land what we want
lures vader to this rocky moon now this
moon is not identified the audio
description calls it a desolate moon or
barren moon that's terrain does look a
bit like the rocky surface of obadiah
home world of the pikes but this is
definitely not obadiah okay you're upset
obi-wan finds lola in one of his pockets
he joked earlier with leia that he
should borrow the droid to be less
afraid and when leia hugged him earlier
there was a lump on her back where lola
was probably tucked and she must have
dropped it in his pocket then remember
this is the same move that's used on her
mother to snatch lola in episode 1.
vader arrives in his lambda class
shuttle and he finds obi-wan waiting for
him in front of the rocky monoliths now
vader by comparison is flanked only by a
misty void and his shuttle wings folded
upward to evoke the shape of a pitchfork
so the monoliths behind obi-wan provide
a nice compositional contrast obi-wan is
facing vader with backup of countless
fallen jedi standing shoulder to
shoulder with him whereas vader is
facing obi-wan alone in the distant
profile shot vader approaches him under
this crescent if it's not a crescent
moon we're on a moon right now that is
the planet that this moon orbits this
now framed above vader and based on the
shadow of that planet's surface and the
lighting of this moon we must be on the
dark side of this moon all the imagery
here also reminding us of the eclipse
that suddenly formed on mustafar over
obi-wan's head as he and anakin began
their duel so we got one shot making
obi-wan look less alone another shot
reminding us that we are in the dark
side with vader still vader asks have
you come to destroy me obi-wan
i will do what i must
then you will die yes paralleling their
pre-dual exchange and revenge of the
sith i will do what i must
you will try then obi-wan strikes the
same aggressive pose that he did with
grievous revenge of the sith and against
maul and rebels i love that pose and
compared to their past duel obi-wan is
far more confident now at one point they
are back-to-back as they were in their
sparring session flashback last episode
meanwhile at the lars homestead riva
ignites her lightsaber as a torch to see
her surroundings which obi-wan showed us
in episode 3 ultimately just blinds you
to the threats lurking in obi-wan and
beru opened fire kicking over those
flower pots that we saw lining the
homestead and the opening act of a new
hope you know how much water these
plants need you know how valuable water
is it's just crazy to think that this
home was getting wrecked like this this
shootout happening in the same place
where luke was hopping around in the
opening act of a new hope and no one
brought it up in while i'm
editorializing here a quick reminder
that the best way to supporting
rockstars is to get our kenobi inspired
empire's most wanted shirt at new
rockstarsmerch.com you'll get the added
option to ride in a custom shout out for
our wikileaks after shows thank you
anyway as we return to vader and obi-wan
we get this roving shot gliding through
the rocky pillars just giving us a sense
of the natural elements they'll be able
to use in this fight and how those rocks
are as much a threat to them as their
blades are obi-wan tries to collapse one
of these pillars on vader but vader
casts it aside and then vader jabs him
in the nose and our heart skips a beat
here because along with the choir voices
under this battle it all evokes phantom
menace remember this is a move maul did
a qui-god to knock the saber from his
hands and then stab him in the chest
remember the one time in star wars
someone has actually died from stabbing
vader then does a vader quake crumbling
the ground beneath obi-wan's feet
submerging him into a sinkhole finally
vader has the high ground now and he
tries to bury obi-wan alive meanwhile
the pole that owen jabs at riva is
actually the same piece of scrap that
han leia luke and chewie tries to use to
brace the walls of the trash compactor
in a new home this prop also showed up
in pelimoto's shop in boba fett oh and
smartly jabs her wound remembering that
the last time they spoke in episode one
she did not have this bandage around her
midsection so he knows uh she's probably
weak there riva throws him off the
walkway and knows how he hurts his knee
he clutches it from the ground there he
walks with a lint for the rest of this
episode setting up uncle owen's tired
gate in a new hope as luke flees across
the desert there is a faint red globe i
think it's just one of the moisture
evaporators behind him but it does have
a scary sinister presence reflecting
riva's pursuit of him meanwhile beneath
the rebel obi-wan holds up the rocks
haunted by voices
yes those are the overlapping voices of
anakin and darth vader anakin from their
episode 5 sparring session vader from
episode 3 anakin's ranting before their
duel and revenge of the sith but obi-wan
is able to silence these painful voices
and replace them with visual flashes of
hope leia on jabim luke outside his home
leia on mapuzo leia getting her green
cloak on daiyu leia's fall from daiyu
where obi-wan first reconnected with the
force luke pretending to be a pilot
wearing the pod racer goggles leia
holding his hand as they left nerd these
are representations of the living force
empowering obi-wan to free himself from
his grave and vader thinking he's one
suddenly stops sensing the threat behind
him similar framing his last episode
when riva snuck up behind him his own
mask and helmet blocking out most of the
frame in episode three it was vader who
got the drop on obi-wan now the tables
have turned obi-wan switches his saber
from one hand to the other behind his
back and then he does that behind the
back twirl that anakin used to love to
do we saw him doing in the sparring
flashback last episode also in the
prequels obi-wan is straight up rubbing
this invader's face now he's trying to
awaken anakin's soul within him whereas
vader used the elements to crumble the
ground beneath obi-wan's feet a downward
assault obi-wan raises the rocks to hurl
them an upward assault more befitting of
a jedi who traditionally raised rocks as
part of their basic training luke
ontagabot grogu on corvus rey on crait
even rogen alluded to floating rocks
back in episode four so does every kid
making a rock flow from here to course
obi-wan hits vader in the helmet with an
elbow jab it's always the punches that
just take these guys down and this
staggers vader enough for obi-wan to
give him the business hack it away at
his control panel yet vader refuses to
yield obi-wan slashes his back and then
kicks off from a boulder for a leaping
strike like achilles and troy slicing
vader's helmet open and exposing his
scarred face you can even see the
scarring at the top of his bald head
anakin
anakin's gone
i am what remains
i love it we hear a mix of hayden
christensen's voice in a distorted mess
along with the recreated reese feature
version of james earl jones vocal
likeness two identities living in one
this whole moment parallels one of the
most heartbreaking reunions in rebels
when ahsoka faced anakin in season two's
twilight of the apprentice
i won't leave you
not this time
then you will die
that moment mixed matt lancher's voice
with james earl jones voice and of
course the other side of vader's helmet
was ripped open i just love the
symbolism of this how it parallels the
exposed eye imagery on all the posters
obi-wan and one of vader's eyes ahsoka
in the other the two jedi his gaze is
forever fixed upon each of them only
half unmasked vader and not until luke
will vader be fully unmasked and return
to the jedi when he is redeemed now i'm
not a skincare aficionado but i prefer
my face to look as young and fresh as it
did when i was just a padawan i want to
take care of the money maker well the
fine folks at geology hooked me up with
some skincare products and i have loved
them geology is a nine-time
award-winning men's skincare company
that creates simple effective
personalized skincare products for men
click the link in this video's
description and take a 30 second quiz
tell them about your skin and their team
of dermatologists designs a regimen just
for you that ships directly to your door
it's great for folks worried about acne
dark eye circles wrinkles or signs of
aging they send you a 30 day trial set
that's easy to incorporate into your
routine whether you are new to skin care
or a seasoned expert so they sent me
vital morning face cream you start out
your morning with that repairing night
cream that's for the end of the day
nourishing eye cream that's just you
know to nourish this region and then
just everyday face wash for like after a
run or something or after you've like
been outside or like me has had layers
and layers of sunscreen on my face and
you just want something to wash it all
off and cleanse it this is your best
friend but really the best part about
all this is that they do the thinking
for me they send me what i need and all
i have to do is use it and they're
offering a crazy deal right now and this
is your last chance to take advantage of
it you can get 70 off on their 30-day
five-piece trial kit head to geology.com
for 70 off on your 30-day trial when you
use the code rockstars rockstars70
or just click the link below remember
this is your last chance to take
advantage of this offer don't miss out
on your opportunity to get 70 off on
your 30-day trial at geology.com promo
code rockstar 70. obi-wan apologizes i'm
sorry
i'm sorry annika
and notice the blue glow lights his face
here and for a moment that same blue
lights anakin's face too you
didn't kill anakin skywalker
i did
the same way
i will destroy you now throughout this
it's mostly hayden's voice but the
respect for james earl jones voice does
kick in for obi-wan and while it seems
like anakin for a moment is forgiving
obi-wan as the blue light remains on his
face when vader reveals it was he who
killed anakin that blue light fades from
obi-wan's face and is replaced with the
color red and then we come back to
vader's face and it is bleeding red it's
just such a cool way of showing the
shift in identities between anakin and
vader and this provides obi-wan with
that certain point of view cover story
that he tells luke in a new hope a young
jedi named darth vader
who was a pupil of mine until he turned
to evil
helped the empire hunt down and destroy
the jedi knights
he betrayed and murdered your father
yeah that's not a lie that obi-wan
invented to spare luke's feelings it is
really the most emotionally true
explanation of what happened here and it
came directly from vader himself obi-wan
says
that my friend is truly dead
goodbye
doth
yeah a little syntax echo of luke in
return the jedi
then my father is truly dead
and finally accepting vader's new
identity he calls him darth setting up
their famous exchange on the death star
when i left you i was but the learner
now i am the master
only a master of evil
obi-wan leaves him behind vader's
screams
[Music]
and i love how the red glow of a saber
really highlights each of the contours
of his scars the reason it glowed red is
because he was raising his lightsaber
not to attack but to use that light to
show all the scarring that obi-wan left
on his face the scream here again the
audio mixing is incredible including
both hayden screaming and the recent
feature james earl jones screaming and
of course reminding us of sam whitware's
epic scream as maul and rebels
reva searches for luke through a canyon
i'm assuming this is beggar's canyon
that has come up a lot riva pulls luke
off the rock ledge and as she approaches
she instead suddenly sees her own young
self lying in that sand and she flashes
among memories to the knight of order 66
and her recent duel with vader on mapuzo
we get this quick new close-up of anakin
a look of pain and uncertainty right
before he struck her that night as if
only now riva is thinking back on that
split second of doubt when anakin could
have made a different choice but then we
see anakin's eyes hardened and he shakes
the doubt out of his mind and riva
realizes that she does not have that
same evil in her heart that anakin had
in that moment i honestly think it was
the sight of luke and his physical
resemblance to his father and how luke
represents the goodness that was once in
anakin and that was what inspired riva
to make a different choice after
returning luke she sobs to obi-wan i
couldn't do it
i feel them
you haven't failed them
by showing mercy
you have given them peace
you have honored them
this may give us some insight to why
obi-wan did not finish off vader before
because by showing mercy he honors the
victims and shows his enemy another path
but you know hey riva if you really want
to honor your friends who died in order
66 you could start by getting that one
younglings corpse out of the amber give
them an ocean burial on nerd i mean it's
a start riva tosses her lightsaber in
the sand relinquishing her mission like
all the other jedi who gave up their
lightsabers on the path and replacing
the two jedi blades buried in the sand
at the beginning of the season with a
double-ended blade back in the sand onto
boostivar where an aerial shot shows
vader's two-pronged castle truly does
function as a dam for lava rivers i love
the design that doug chang's team put
into this in rogue one this is a literal
dam for lava like how in our world dams
often serve as hydroelectric stations
generating energy in this case it's a
dam of the lava with a tuning fork
design harnessing and channeling dark
side energy fueling vader's rage the
longer he sits there vader communes with
the emperor ian mcdarmond making a cameo
i wonder if your thoughts
are clear on this
lord vader perhaps your feelings for
your old master
have left you weakened
if your past cannot be overcome
yeah i like how ian mcdarma's eyes go
from a judging squint to a more
threatening glare and he leaves that
sentence unfinished letting vader fill
in the blank mentally the subtext of
course is according to the sith rule of
two all of the dark side apprentice's
feelings hatred included must be focused
on their master palpatine is implying
that even vader hating obi-wan amounts
to an emotional betrayal invader knowing
that the grand inquisitor is waiting in
the wings does not want to be replaced
our final shot of vader brings back john
williams amazing imperial march and the
camera pulls back from him on his throne
his throne room with the red windows and
the steps evoking the appearance of
vader's mask the steps being his
breathing grilled windows his eyes now
angled downward making him look angrier
than ever on alderaan leia now dresses
herself a contrast to the episode 1
images of handmaidens dressing the girl
we thought was leia she has an intricate
braid a precursor to the one she has in
a new hope she wears tala's holster and
brea approves leia's look here with the
boots rip like sir action fit that we
saw in the age of rebellion comics
obi-wan returns with lola and bail
organa says i fear for her future
[Music]
the empire grows stronger
and
bolder
well if you ever need my help again
you know where to find me yeah we feel
echoes of the doomed fate of alderaan
and bail organa in a new hope but until
then we will have andorr where bale may
make an appearance alongside senator mon
makma as they both work to covertly
subvert the empire diplomatically
obi-wan tells leia
you are wise
discerning
kind-hearted
these are qualities that came from your
mother
but you're also
passionate
and fearless
forthright
and these are gifts from your father
[Music]
both were exceptional people
who bore an exceptional daughter i'm not
crying all of us are crying yes that is
john williams leia theme there and it's
beautiful obi-wan of course paying
tribute to padme and anakin and how
their best qualities do live on in their
children back home apuzzo obi-wan said
that he wished he could have been leia's
dad and now with these words he's
realizing he doesn't need to be because
he continues to say i wish i could tell
you more
it's okay
yet or not
yeah just her look at bale and brea
already moving on leia signals that
these two are the only parents she needs
she asks
will i ever see you again reminding us
of anakin with smee and phantom menace i
ever see you again
and within against me the next time you
did see her she was dying as the next
time leia will see obi-wan unless
lucasfilm decides to sandwich even more
lore in here will be leia's eye line
connecting with obi-wan briefly on the
death star the moment of his death in a
new hope obi-wan says goodbye princess
may the force be with you and of course
john williams force theme returns there
back on tatooine obi-wan packs up his
stuff into saddlebags and a crate
remember anakin's lightsaber is stored
among this stuff waiting to be handed
off to luke years from now compared to
his wardrobe in episode one obi-wan now
wears brighter robes and with those
goggles his look is now straight out of
the 2015 jason aaron mike mayu star wars
number 15 with obi-wan on the cover
which is set in the years after this
obi-wan finds that old t-16 skyhopper
toy that he tried to give to luke before
owen threw back at him so he rides the
ob back to the homestead and tells owen
that it is okay for luke to stay a kid
you don't need to train a kid to be a
jedi it only leads to bad things obi-wan
says the future will take care of itself
and owen lets obi-wan finally meet luke
face to face he gives him the t-16 that
luke will play with in a new hope and he
says the line
hello there
and luke how do we respond hello there
and in the final scene obi-wan rides up
on a mirage that manifests as the force
ghost of qui-gon jinn liam neeson
returning to cameo kind of like rey
spotting luke and leia's force ghost and
the rise of skywalker in these same
desert winds it is implied to be a
mirage in the mind of the perceiver but
does that make that any less real
ultimately i just love that anytime the
tatooine locals saw crazy old ben kenobi
talking to himself he was probably just
talking to qui-gon's ghost he says well
took you long enough beginning to think
you'd never come i was always here
obi-wan we just
we're not ready to see
come on
you've got a ways to go
yeah obi-wan taunts his master the same
way anakin taunted him in their memory i
was beginning to think you were incoming
now notice that qygon's lightsaber is
not visible under his robes our man
always kept it tucked away under the
robes and anakin really only from his
low vantage point was able to see it
briefly in phantom menace and even after
that qui-gon played coy about even
having a lightsaber throughout these six
episodes obi-wan has always been praying
to qui-gon's ghost in hopes of communing
with him as yoda promised they would at
the end of revenge of the sith but
obi-wan has only been met with silence
but that silence was actually just
deafness and blindness to what was
always there as quinlan vos's quote read
only when the eyes are closed can you
truly see the way obi-wan needed to
close his eyes to his haunting past let
the past die kill it if you have to
including all of his memories with
anakin and instead focus on the living
force as qui-gon counseled him in the
opening change of phantom menace down
center on your anxieties everyone keep
your concentration here and now where it
belongs
but master yoda said i should be mindful
of the future but not at the expense of
the moment be mindful of the living
force young padawan you probably noticed
that the imagery here focuses on
footprints in the sand evoking the
classic christian footprints in the sand
metaphor one set of the prince because
it was in those times i was carrying you
obi-wan began this series divorced from
the force and every time his thoughts
brought him back in sync with vader
their shared memory last episode that i
believe was truly qui-gon jinn playing
force matchmaker to reacquaint obi-wan
with the living force thank you so much
for joining me on all these breakdowns
of obi-wan kenobi if you live in the san
francisco bay area you can actually see
me live with endgames improv every other
saturday including this saturday june
25th hit me up on twitter for more
details at ea boss follow me rockstar
subscribe to the rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching goodbye
[Music]
you
[Music]